the people who looted this almaty
shopping mall knew no one was coming to
stop them not only did they steal new
shoes
they had time to leave their old ones
behind
[Music]
this store owner estimates damages at
over a hundred thousand dollars
the guys who did the looting mostly men
right but they still took all the
lingerie everything's gone
on tuesday president tokyo did not say
how he would help business recover from
an estimated 57 million dollars in
losses but he did promise social
economic and political reforms and
strikingly a crackdown on the country's
oligarchs who must pay into a new
national fund
thanks to the first president
a group of very profitable companies and
a layer of people rich even by
international standards have appeared in
the country i believe that it's time to
pay tribute to the people of kazakhstan
and help them systematically and
regularly
relatives of former president nor sultan
nazarbayev have amassed fabulous wealth
in taking it abroad
it's estimated that his daughter and
son-in-law own properties in london
alone worth over 350 million dollars
slightly more than half of national
wealth is held offshore it is probably a
reasonable estimate so you're talking
about more than half of all the wealth
in the country is outside the scrutiny
of the government and therefore
if the owners of that wealth decide not
to participate in the new national fund
then that wealth will not participate in
the new national fund there's nothing
the government can do about that
tokyo says foreign troops will leave
within 10 days he seems confident he no
longer needs the moscow-backed military
force to hold on to power
from the prime minister down loyal
deputies are being appointed the key
issue to what extent he will be able to
repair the economy to take it out of
this corrupted
criminal
oligarchic type of
ruling and secondly how he will be able
to re redistribute the wealth
to
make to narrow these social gaps and
social inequality and social injustice
if he will be able to do so this is the
best way of healing
there's much healing to do
widespread damage to both the private
and public sectors more than 160 people
have died thousands injured this is a
traumatized nation hoping the nazarbayev
era is drawing to a close
but wary of what comes next
roman forestier walker al jazeera